Babies are getting better and better with
technology.
They still suck at driving though, so…
I’ve got them there.
Welcome to DNews, I’m Ross Everett and I’m
better than a baby.
Sure, baby’s are tiny balls of meat that
somehow have managed to make being bald adorable,
but the question everyone is asking, for the
sake of this news piece, is at what age should
they be allowed to use digital media?
There are videos on the internet of babies
using smart phones like it’s second nature,
swishing and swiping.
Tapping and turning, all as if it’s an extension
of themselves.
Which is terrifying.
They’re advancing quicker than we’ve ever
imagined.
Next thing you know, they’re going to get
older and take over our jobs just like humans
have been doing for generations!
But the question remains, at how young is
too young to use this type of technology?
The American Pediatric Association says that
screens should be avoided before the age of
two, but they also lump passively watching
TV into the same category as the interactive
and participatory use of smartphones and tablets
which seems absurd.
Well, it’s possible that children under
the age of two might not be able to distinguish
the difference between the two screens.
Minds that young can’t comprehend what we
call dual representation, which is the ability
to look at a photo of a car and know that
it is both a picture and a representation
of a car.
Child psychologists also point out that interactive
apps can interfere with a child’s story
comprehension.
Apps lack the necessary range and linguistic
cues of a human speaker, which are crucial
for early language development in kids as
they need to be able to try mimicking facial
expressions, gestures, tones of voice and
body language.
Which is why I sound so much like my mother
and father when I talk, and not like an app.
But, come on!
We’re not at a place where technology could
adopt natural sounding voices?
I call shenanigans.
Quality matters, though, and while children’s
print books go through a competitive peer
review process, sometimes with years of experts
weighing in with opinion, app store review
guidelines for children’s apps are way quicker
by comparison.
Not to mention the lack of variation an app
conveys the world to be compared to the actual
world.
And it’s reported that touch is the number
one means of communication and learning in
early childhood, so when we replace squeezing
and chewing, with swiping and tapping children
might be missing out on some very important
developmental tools.
Of course, it’s impossible and impractical
to keep babies away from the devices that
are everywhere in our lives, but this is merely
a report on the importance of continuing real
life contact and interactions with children
instead of letting a device raise and teach
the child so we can continue letting our devices
run our lives.
In fact, some of you might be watching this
on one right now…
What do you think, how much screen time is
too much screen time for children?
Let me know in the comments down below.
And if you’re curious about if Internet
addiction is a real thing, I was in a video
over on The New Show that explains how it
could actually be worse than alcohol withdrawal.